وضع انساني يتفاقم بتفاقم الازمه التي
يشهدها السودان والاسوا هو صعوبه تلبيه
الخدمه الانسانيه والصحيه الاساسيه في خضم
الصراع الدموي الذي تشهده البلاد والذي
ادى بحياه 185 شخصا واصابه 1800 وفق الامم
المتحده اما نقابه اطباء السودان فقد
اعلنت عن 174 حاله وفاه واكثر من 1200
اصابه حصيله اعتبارها السكان في الخرطوم
اقل من اعداد الضحايا على ارض الواقع
حصار لايام حرم الاهالي في الخرطوم وما
حولها من معظم الخدمات الاساسيه ما يصعب
تقديم العون على منظمات الاغاثه بحسب
الاتحاد الدولي لجمعيات الصليب الاحمر
والهلال الاحمر والذي اكد على وجود
الامكانات لكن انعدام الممرات الانسانيه
هو ما عرقل الوضع
الحصار تجاوز البر الى الجو ليكون اغلاق
مطار السودان وجميع الاجواء السودانيه حجر
عثره اخرى في وجه المساعدات بحسب صحيفه
الكورديان
ازمه طالت القطاع الصحي ايضا لتكون
المشافي في مرمى النيران فقد اغلقت 39 من
اصل 59 مشفى في الخرطوم ومحيطها الابواب
امام الجرح والمرضى بسبب تضرر البنيه
التحتيه الصحيه وفق النقابه اطباء السودان
حقيقه الوضع الانساني وضع كارثه والنظام
الصحي الان يمكننا ان نقول انه منار تماما
يظل تعرض عدد من المستشفيات للقصف المباشر
وخروجها عن الخدمه
ادانتها منظمه صحه العالميه مسميه اياها
انتهاكا خطيرا معلنه مقتل ثلاثه على الاقل
من العاملين في المجال الصحي بالاضافه
لتوقف عشرات المشاف عن العمل
الهجمات على مرافق الرعايه الصحيه انتهاك
صارخ للقانون الدولي والحق في الصحه ويجب
وقفها على الفور اطباء بلا حدود التي
انشات مشفا في دارفور خلال 48 ساعه
استقبلت ما يقارب 136 جريحا توفي منهم 11
شخصا متاثرين بجراحهم
كما ابدت المنظمات قلقها من نقص المعدات
الطبيه التي قد يودي بحياه المزيد وما زاد
من عبئ مهامها اعتراض المقاتلين في
الخرطوم لسيارات الاسعاف التي تنقل الجرحى
او حتى الجثث اذا عمر العربيه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات